i am repulsed today
truly repulsed by having to do this
story
but we are seeing a massive coveted
resurgence right now
which is leading to some countries in
stating health passes
new vaccine requirements speculative
third
vaccine doses and much much more and
it's all because we aren't vaccinating
enough people
in some parts of the world because they
don't yet have vaccines
in the united states because we have so
many ignorant anti-vaxxers
here in the united states daily cases
are now up listen to this
69 69
cases up in the united states globally
cases are now up 24 what is happening
the delta variant combined with not
enough vaccination
okay the delta variant is about 60 more
contagious
than the original variant it's spreading
yes
mostly among unvaccinated people that is
a testament to the effectiveness of the
vaccines but it's not exclusively among
the unvaccinated
because the vaccines aren't 100
effective and the vaccines were not
designed
specifically to be tailored to the delta
variant and right now
as many people in the united states
continue to refuse to get vaccinated
things are increasingly pointed to a
very ugly fall of 2021.
i am fully expecting at this point you
know three months ago i said
in the fall um as we get into flu season
i would be fine with saying hey we've
got to go back to masks at the grocery
store and stuff like that
at this point i am fully expecting that
masks are coming back on in the fall
in a widespread manner unless people
really go out and get vaccinated right
now now as a result
look at what's going on around the world
remember much of the world doesn't yet
have access to vaccines like we have in
the u.s
in france the president emmanuel macron
is putting in place new health rules
including the eu digital covit
certificate some people call this the
health pass
and it's going to be mandatory if you
want to go to any cultural venue
if you want to go to the movies you will
have to be using the health pass
starting in august the health pass will
be mandatory to go to cafes
shops and restaurants as well as trains
and planes among other places
france is also going to require
healthcare workers
be vaccinated if they want to continue
working around patients
and in healthcare settings in israel one
of the most
vaccinated countries in the world they
are now starting
third doses of the pfizer vaccine for
the most
at-risk adults why it's relatively
speculative there's the idea
that a third dose might provide more
protection
particularly for at-risk folks it is not
something that the who says is indicated
the who says let's keep giving first
doses
to completely unvaccinated people but
desperation is growing
as even israel is seeing okay it's a
very little increase in cases
israel is so highly vaccinated that it's
not a big increase
but there are more breakthrough cases
happening in israel as well as delta
variant cases
among people who have not been
vaccinated tennessee
has now fired its top vaccine official
because
19 is showing signs of massive spread in
tennessee
california cases are now up 181 percent
compared to the previous week
so is there any good news the good news
continues to be we have a tool that
works really well against the delta
variant if we all use it
and when a vaccinated person does get
infected
they are overwhelmingly completely
asymptomatic
most breakthrough vaccinated infections
are asymptomatic
not all and there are vaccinated people
who have died
understand that now in the u.s officials
are saying
almost all recent hospitalizations and
deaths are unvaccinated people and
that's true
but not all and this is a community
effort this is a joint effort here
there are countries that as they get
access to the vaccine
are already seeing way more interest in
getting it than we've seen in the united
states look at canada for example
canada got significant vaccine access
much later than the united states
and yet they're quickly catching up to
the u.s in terms of per capita
second doses so we need to deal with
anti-vaxxers
somehow and there are real concerns
about what things look like in the fall
if we don't do that just look at the
numbers these are not vague you know
it's so easy to hear these headlines oh
it's more contagious
oh some people don't want to get and
have some
total disconnect from the fact that this
means people
develop symptoms that get so bad that
they go to the hospital and some of them
never come out
and it can mostly be avoided just by
going and getting vaccinated so
the fall i understand that this is
becoming overwhelmingly
a pandemic of the unvaccinated but
not completely and it's not as simple as
well
if you don't want to get vaccinated
you're the only one at risk that is not
the case
all right so as we head into the fall
we're going to continue
watching this by the way also as we head
into the fall
the david pakman show will be hitting
our 16
year anniversary our 16th anniversary i
believe is the right way to say it
and in fact on august 16th we will be
doing a
one-day 16-year membership blowout i
would love for you to
join the ranks of membership to
celebrate our 16th year
um and really the start of the 17th year
right
uh okay and um you can be notified of
that on august 16th just by getting on
our membership
on our newsletter you can sign up for it
at davidpakman.com
and let me know your thoughts about
where you see the pandemic
going in the fall by sending me a
message on twitter
deepakman